dès septembre prochain cette classe
accueillera sept nouveaux élèves des
petits yvelinois âgé de trois ans est
atteint d'autisme ou de troubles
envahissants du développement
cette unité d'enseignement maternel
autisme appelé uem est une première dans
le département
une enseignante spécialisée expérimenté
s'occupera de cette classe j'attends
cette ouverture depuis depuis très très
longtemps
effectivement l'autisme c'est un
handicap qui a été très peu reconnu ces
dernières années deux qu'ils ont besoin
d'un espace de travail très restreint
individualisé avec très peu de stimuli
visuels et auditifs
donc il faut aménager l'espace de
manière à ce qu'ils puissent entrer dans
les apprentissages sans être perturbé
par tout ce qu'il ya autour
l'initiative est inscrite dans le
troisième plan autisme initié en 2013
les conventions relatives à cette
création ont été signés vendredi 17 juin
par le rectorat
l'association autisme en yvelines la
ville est l' agence régionale de santé
qui encadre ce dispositif
ces enfants vont bénéficier à la fois
d'une prise en charge par un enseignant
donc met à disposition par l'éducation
nationale mais également par des
personnels médicaux sociaux c'est à dire
donc un temps de psychiatres un temps de
psychologues 1 et enfin trois éducateurs
trois équivalents temps-plein
d'éducateurs un chef de service
l'appel à projet avait été lancé en fin
d'année 2015 le groupe scolaire willy
brandt d'elancourt a été choisi pour son
espace et son investissement dans le
numérique
reconnu pour faciliter l'accessibilité à
l'apprentissage de ses enfants
robot et tablettes devraient faire
partie des équipements pour montrent que
le numérique aussi peu améliorée
la compréhension améliorer le travail
scolaire l'apprentissage d'un enfant qui
comme comme saint thomas à
le repli sur soi à un problème liste une
chute dans les contextes sociaux à un
peu isolée du du monde donc il s'agit de
deux par ce travail intellectuel
différencier où ils puissent treuil à
son rythme lui est propre chef que les
outils numériques vous permet de
travailler votre propre rythme le projet
a été proposé par l'association autisme
en yvelines
l'association dispose d'un service
d'éducation spéciale et de soins à
domicile et connaît bien les
problématiques des enfants autistes
comme son président dont le fils est
atteint par la maladie
les places en établissements spécialisés
sont très rares donc là gros avantage de
gros intérêts de l'ue m
telle qu'on ouvre ici à elancourt c'est
qu'on en est capable d'intégrer très tôt
même quand le diagnostic est pas
entièrement posé son enfant dans une
classe d'inclusion dans un école dans
une école ordinaire et ça c'est une
chance inouïe 17 % des élèves scolarisés
cette année dans le département sont
atteints de troubles envahissants du
comportement d'autres unités
d'enseignements de ce type devraient
être créés une centaine d'enfants et
binoy sans solution de scolarisation
attendent toujours d'être pris en charge